so I've played a lot of video games in
my day whether I'm playing Fallout or
The Sims or runescape just to clarify I
don't still play runescape I've noticed
there's a commonality to pretty much
every game and that's this idea that
when you upgrade your character your
traits and your skills you get to unlock
new abilities new opportunities travel
to new parts of the map and wield better
stuff you know in runescape if you want
to wear rune armor you got to grind it
out fight like a billion goblins or
guards and grind your defense level to
level 40 in the sims if you want to make
any money whatsoever
you got to pick a skill max it out and
then you can start making money and in
Fallout New Vegas if you try to make it
to New Vegas before you upgrade your
character and your stats and your perks
and stuff you're gonna get completely
manhandled by a flying bug even though
this is kind of a shower thought it
really got me thinking about how life
kind of works in the exact same way by
upgrading your skills developing your
talents acquiring positive personality
traits it really opens up a lot of new
opportunities in life you get to travel
to new parts of the map when you start
making more money and you get to wield
better stuff and although this is pretty
obvious I feel like we as human beings
forget about this a lot we focus a ton
on outcomes we want to pay off our
student loans or we want to get a
girlfriend or we want to move out of our
crappy apartment into a nicer part of
town we get very caught up in all the
good things we want to have happen to us
completely ignoring the fact that some
sort of personal transformation likely
needs to happen in order for these
things to actually happen or at least
have a higher likelihood of happening
we're always tempted to look outside of
ourselves for the solutions to our
problems but we forget that often our
situation is just a symptom of our
character the character we're playing as
our ever-growing debt is often just a
symptom of our bad spending habits and
our inability as a person to delay
gratification our lack of friends might
be a symptom of our lack of confidence
and low self-esteem but we don't like to
realize that we don't like to admit that
maybe we're the ones that need working
on and
been going to the doctor one day because
you wake up your whole body's in pain
maybe you have a history of I don't know
a bone disease or something in your
family and you're really concerned and
scared so you go to the doctor looking
for answers and the doctors like hmmm
pain right here have some painkillers
you consider him a pretty crappy doctor
because he's not actually trying to
investigate what the root cause of the
issue is he's just treating the symptom
but that's exactly how we often treat
ourselves and our own problems it's like
standing at the shore trying to push the
waves away and prevent them from hitting
the shore with your hands it's just so
futile you might stop a couple of them
but the waves they're just gonna keep on
coming all of this to say one simple
idea that's really helped me trend my
life in an upward direction is to focus
on internal improvement rather than
external improvement instead of shopping
for a sexy new wardrobe that'll make me
feel more confident and give me a little
bit of swagger in my step I stop myself
and I think what's something I can work
on internally that will help me achieve
the exact same goal you know how can I
feel confident without having to buy
something or get something usually that
means getting off my butt and developing
more discipline at the gym having a
great workout starting to eat better
these are things that will help me feel
a sense of accomplishment and make me
feel proud of Who I am which will make
me feel a lot more confident than a new
shirt ever could or if I'm feeling like
my videos aren't cinematic enough and
I'm really tempted to pull the trigger
on a really expensive cinema camera on
B&H I stop myself and think about what's
something I can work on internally that
will help me achieve that cinema look
well the answer is pretty obvious maybe
I should learn how to light things
better frame things better work on my
composition upgrading my skills as a
filmmaker will do a lot more to improve
myself
as a filmmaker than buying a new camera
usually the best answers to our problems
lie within ourselves and they're really
unexcited and they're not as stimulating
as buying something or getting something
but they're the actual way to solve the
problem and the nice thing about
focusing on internal improvement right
than external improvement is that you
develop a sort of resiliency to the
chaos of life because truth is anything
that you get or attain or any external
upgrade you can make can be taken away
from you in the blink of an eye whether
that's a pandemic sweeping the nation
and you end up losing a job that you
worked really hard to get or maybe the
economy crashes and you lose all the
investments that you made and if you
spent all your time putting your eggs in
the external basket and it all goes away
overnight
then you're left with pretty much
nothing but if you spent your time
investing in yourself internally then if
you lose all the things you've worked on
externally you've developed the
character to bounce back from chaos you
develop skills that makes you valuable
to your community and your family and
yourself you can make something out of
nothing
and you can be somebody who naturally
creates good outcomes rather than
somebody who's just focusing on changing
the outcomes themselves without
developing the necessary character
needed to actually reliably produce them
so to wrap this whole thing up
just remember this relationship between
building your character and upgrading
your life if you focus on upgrading your
character then the outcomes have a
natural tendency to take care of
themselves
one of the best ways you can invest in
yourself is to constantly be learning
new things and developing your skills
which is why today's video sponsor skill
share is such a perfect sponsor for
today's video as many of you know I'm
constantly trying to develop my
filmmaking and cinematography skill and
thankfully there are a ton of classes
for me on Skillshare including DIY
cinematography by Ryan booth which I'm
really enjoying so far for those of you
who don't know skill share is an online
learning community with thousands of
classes covering dozens of topics
everything from filmmaking to
productivity to how to manage your inbox
pretty much any skill you want to work
on there's probably a class for it on
Skillshare and one of the things I love
about skill share is that it empowers
you to accomplish real growth because
all of their classes are designed for
real life they're extremely practical so
you can absorb what you're learning on
Skillshare and really apply it to your
real-life pursuits it's also extremely
affordable especially when you compare
it to real life classes and workshops
which can run you hundreds and hundreds
of dollars every single week but if you
join skill shares annual membership it
comes in at less than $10 a month so
it's kind of a no-brainer skill share is
also doing this cool thing where the
first 500 of you that click the link
below get two months of skill share
premium absolutely free so make sure you
hit that up explore your creativity and
as usual have a great time if you like
this video make sure to hit like because
when you hit like the algorithm blesses
me and it shoves my bald head into
people's home pages potentially helping
them out which also helps me out so it's
a win-win for everybody if you're
lurking here consider subscribing and
hitting that Bell icon so that you don't
miss future uploads other than that hit
me up on Instagram or Twitter if you
want to just follow me around or check
out the second channel I'm going to be
posting there more often
[Music]
don't that monitor turned off I have
been posting there more often but other
than that that's all for today thanks so
much for watching and we'll catch you
the next video
[Music]
Stephen whoa
thank God you showed up you would not
believe the symptoms I'm going through
right now man yeah a lot of people who
come in here are pretty sick mm-hmm you
got me thinking though what would happen
if everyone was sick if everyone's sick
then no one's sick technically right
yeah yes it says here that you've been
experiencing some issues I just woke up
this morning terrible dry cough my whole
body's just in pain
I'm checking off every single symptom of
that virus that's going around hmm
pretty scared about that so I don't know
if you need to just swab me have you
seen any other doctors about this No
very well very well so do you think I
haven't I don't know so you said you're
experiencing a cough right well you're
in luck I have just the thing for that
I have halls cherry and halls mint mint
this is Hall's mint you're not a very
good doctor no not really